[Music]
there are plenty of iconic skins in cs
go
the dragon war the caramel the
weeb-tacular akihabara except but no
skin in cs go is more
legendary than the m4a4 howell
oh my god oh my god
one thing one more time
oh damn
daniel now again as we've seen so many
times before it's down to hiko but
against four is it really possible
we do have a few players quite tagged up
here from luminosity so hiko definitely
not going down without a fight oh wow
there's a first fast frag heco gets a
double there's still two players left
they got no health on them
13 and three heco
creeping around the site now there's
still time oh my goodness how does he do
this
how does he go do it again
when valve introduced a skin market back
in 2013 no one could have ever predicted
that one day
a skin would sell for six figures
how could that even be possible well to
answer that
we have to go back to the very beginning
of cs go skins
eight years ago valve rolled out skins
as part of the arms deal update for csgo
following in the footsteps of team
fortress 2 where valve first
experimented in microtransactions with
hats
it was only a matter of time before cs
go got a virtual marketplace of its own
unlike pretty much any other games out
there valve games use the steam workshop
to allow
people to submit their own skins and
those that are popular enough can
actually make it into the game this has
led to tons of amazing skins making it
into cs go
even though most of what's out there is
not great
anyway the skin workshop was a great
idea but like all great ideas
it didn't take long for people to start
abusing the system and there's no more
glaring instance of people abusing the
skin market than the story of csgo's
most coveted
most controversial and most legendary
skin
the m4a4 howl this weapon
these weapons will never be obtainable
again
you can't get him from the trade-off
contract you can't get him from
the huntsman case obviously since
they've got replaced
and you know they're they've just become
really rare now
it all started back in 2014 when steam
users aussie and six submitted the
original howling dawn sticker and
m4a4 howell skinned to the market their
submission received 4
500 upvotes which was more than enough
for the howl to be included in the
upcoming huntsman collection
aussie said the inspiration for his work
came from a picture of his dog
which well i think youtuber jesus put it
best
this is your dog your dog looks like
this your
cerebus is a pet or something how's this
thing not killed you yet
another youtuber alex j gate offered a
similar sentiment i don't know
what kind of dog this guy has right but
that's not
like it doesn't look like a dog to me
like come on that the face of that thing
looks like a snake an
alligator slightly but not a dog what
the hell anyway
weird looking dog aside people did like
the skin it was relatively popular and
it did look cool but then just a few
weeks later
something strange happened not even a
month after the howl came out
valve was slapped with a dmca takedown
notice from a deviantart user named
canis albus
the young finnish artist posted the
following to their blog
looking familiar someone has stolen one
of my artworks to make a custom skin for
a gun in a game called counter-strike
global offensive
the name of the weapon is m4a4 howling
dawn i'm just letting you know that i
did design this piece but i didn't
upload the items to the steam
marketplace
and the spineless worm who submitted it
didn't have my permission to do so
however i've reported both copyright
infringements and i'm hoping that the
items will be removed soon
valve was obviously a little bit nervous
about how all this would affect their
burgeoning skin economy so they acted
quickly
aussie and sick got a lifetime community
banned they would receive no proceeds
from the sales of their skins
and valve also tightened up their rules
around intellectual property
but here's where things get really
interesting for owners of the m4a4
howell and howlingdon sticker
those items have been replaced by an
alternative designed by the cs go team
these items will never be produced again
and have been assigned the contraband
rarity so instead of just wiping out all
memory of the howl completely and
deleting it from the game forever
valve instead decided to put the skin in
its own special category
thus making it one of the most desirable
and rarest skins on the market
to get more insight on this really
strange chain of events we reached out
to the champion
of the skin trading community zipple you
have the
distinctive label the orange label that
is contraband that they made
specifically for the skin
which is to me kind of absurd that they
went out of the way to make a completely
new category of
of exterior just to another exterior of
rarity uh just for stolen artwork that
they redesigned right
so that that in the first place is kind
of absurd and and something that i think
nobody would have
guessed that they would ever do so i
think that adds obviously to the
the mystique of of of the how and then
not only that the redesign i believe
was much better than the original design
and it's still
you know too many people the best
looking m4 in the game
and while the howl is by no means the
only skin to have been put in csgo that
infringed on someone's copyright
it is the only one that's ever been
labeled contraband take the
m4 griffin for example while it's not as
blatant a rip-off as the howl was
the griffin did receive a dmca takedown
notice because it turned out to be
traced from another artist's work
but as youtuber jesus explains in
another video valve's reaction to the
griffon was totally different
there was a lot of very exciting
investors convinced that the gryphon was
going to be the next contraband skin
and now valve did not make the griffin
contraband
they just changed the artwork and left
it as a restrictive skin in the vanguard
collection
today you can get your hands on a
factory new stat track m4 griffin for
about 35
between the fact that it never got the
sexy contraband label
or the possibility that there were just
more griffins out there before the
copyright controversy happened
the griffin never got the same
eye-popping price tag as the howl
and don't worry we'll get to the six
figures thing at the end of the day
most skins don't gain their value
through controversy they get it because
of hype
take skadoodle's dragon lore for example
this skin
encapsulates the moment where cloud9
became the first north american major
champions
ever they weren't the favorites they
were the underdogs they were a heavy
underdogs
but they did it for north america
skadoodles won the majority
it's understandable why skin traders at
the time wanted to own a piece of cs go
history
and it might even explain why someone
shelled out 61
000 for the skin but even that pales in
comparison to what an m4a4 howell goes
for
because last year a chinese skin
collector bought one for a hundred
thousand dollars the skin also came with
four incredibly rare eyebuy power
kadavitse 2014 sticker slapped on the
side making it
one of the most valuable pieces of cs go
memorabilia in history
now some of you might be saying that
none of it is real that the skins are
just a bunch of polygons on your
computer and you don't really own
anything but zipple doesn't think the
price is that crazy
it makes sense because the the m4 in
question there
was a really low float uh non-dupe with
you know four stickers that
will cost you sixty thousand dollars to
apply so the
if you consider the base price of these
data effects you knew how they were
applied to
um with the stickers the price point is
not really that absurd to me
zipl suggests that the price of skins
has been skyrocketing because of china's
growing interest in cs go
the value of high tier items are also
reaching all-time highs
by the purchasing power of china so
examples here could be
that two of the same star trek minimum
ware 661
scar pattern aks with four titan holes
sold for 150k each within a week of each
other
and you have multiple sales reaching
more than 100k
on on four titan holo items four by
powerhole items you have souvenir
draculaura selling for 100k
so it is not slowing down at all
over the past year the supply of
high-tier cs go items like dragon wars
howls and rare knives
have been bought up by chinese
collectors in droves
it is very evident that it's
concentrated in china because every time
there is
there is uh good news from china in
terms of like you know them introducing
the official version of cs in china high
tier skins go up
when there is chinese new year and they
need to take some time off or spend time
with their family or whatever skins drop
it's just you can literally follow like
the chinese vacations and stuff like
that with how the market
performs it's crazy although other sales
have already dwarfed the 100k
howell from last year the m4a4 howell is
still probably the most
valuable skin in cs go when you subtract
stickers specific patterns and souvenir
items from the equation
it's crazy to think that this all
started because valve had a really weird
response to someone stealing some art
from another person who had
no interest in counter-strike to begin
with maybe the howl has become so
valuable because of how
crazy this whole story is but maybe it's
so valuable because
it just looks really cool thanks for
watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you